kevin we know you do documentary
workshops you just finished one at the
writer's store
what are some of the questions that
you're most frequently asked
during these
interactive documentary workshops well
probably the number one question is how
do you fund a documentary and that's
always the most difficult aspect of it
i found that
they're very interested in doing a
documentary obviously at a lower price
point if there's especially if they're
just starting
so we've developed a um
a budget where i can show people how for
five or ten thousand dollars a micro
budget including buying the equipment
you can actually go out and make a
documentary now that's
if you can do a lot of the roles
yourself so if you can teach yourself
how to be the cameraman and the sound
person or the editor or do the color
grading or the scoring if you're a
one-man band you can certainly do it for
very little money if you're doing a
documentary on your neighbor or somebody
that's
that you know that's interesting and you
don't have a lot of travel and a lot of
other crew positions so i get asked a
lot about budget
and then i get asked a lot about well
how do you actually start and and we go
we take them through the entire process
you have to have a
topic that interests you
that will sustain your interest for six
months or six weeks or four years you
know in the case of searching for sugar
man
uh you need something that really you
can stay with for a long time because
these things sometimes the funding comes
in a little
little pieces and
it can be a long process so i'm asked a
lot about funding about how you start
and just basically about the nuts and
bolts of how do you construct how do you
build this documentary
you